welcome to max tech and this is our six
month review of the ipad mini 6.
[Music]
it's been over six months since apple
released the ipad mini 6 and i've got to
be honest with you guys this is by far
my favorite ipad for doing ipad things
now when i say that i'm separating ipad
things and professional things because
the 11 inch ipad pro is by far a much
better ipad in terms of also being a
professional laptop replacement but if
you're just trying to get an ipad and
enjoying it for consuming media watching
movies watching shows playing games or
just browsing the web surfing through
twitter or whatever else this is where
it's at now i know that might surprise
you because the new ipad air 5 was just
released and it has a bunch of upgrades
including the famed m1 chip but i
actually like this better now before i
explain all the reasons why i want to
get into my experience or my thoughts on
the ipad mini 6 after six months now the
two things that really set this ipad
mini 6 apart from the other ipads in the
lineup are first of all the compact size
with the new redesign and of course
number two is the price you can get this
thing for 500 so you're saving money
compared to the higher end ipads and it
has just about the perfect size for an
ipad doing all those things like
consuming media and of course it has the
new redesign which is super super nice
compared to the budget ipad which is
still using that old home button design
i absolutely love basically every single
part of the design of the ipad mini
first of all those flat sides the
thickness is just perfect for holding it
the speaker grilles on both the top and
bottom look really good you got the
volume buttons on top including the new
touch id power button which honestly i
don't prefer that compared to face id on
the ipad pro but of course this is a
much cheaper device and hopefully in the
future apple does bring face id to the
ipad mini going around to the back i
really love how you have that single
camera design you've got the flash which
of course the new ipad air still doesn't
have and just overall everything is just
so proportionate and of course you got
the usbc port which is a huge upgrade
compared to lighting i mean this is the
cheapest way to get a usbc port on an
ipad and it just works so well and where
i think apple absolutely nailed it is
the compact size because this is not
only perfect for me for consuming media
having a larger display than on an
iphone and just holding in your hands
like this super comfortable you can type
or you can hold it in landscape mode
just so much comfort for doing things
like gaming but the real sweet spot is
when it comes to children if you have
kids this is the perfect size i let my
son use this about six months ago when
he was still only one year old then he
was able to hold it in his hands and
watch some movies or some cartoons
perfectly fine as a little kid a little
one-year-old and now my favorite part
about this ipad mini is that it comes
with the latest a15 bionic chip with the
five core gpu which means it packs a ton
of graphics power and overall processing
power inside of it which means that if
you buy this ipad mini you're gonna be
good for the next five or plus years
because it handles basically every app
and game with ease and it doesn't heat
up it's just so impressive and in terms
of gaming support this is actually very
impressive because you can play any game
at perfect 60 fps and just to prove it
to you guys look at golden reviewers
tests of ganshin impact which is by far
the most demanding ios or ipad os game
and he basically got a perfect 60 fps
beating out all of the other mobile
phones including the iphone 13 pro max
because this thing is able to stay cool
enough for the chip to run at full
performance giving you perfect solid 60
fps so that means any game you play is
gonna run perfectly smoothly on this
ipad mini which makes it so good and in
terms of usability while gaming
this is literally the perfect size for
gaming you hold it in your hands it's
like having a game controller you can
fit everything your thumbs all across
the screen it's just so convenient
especially with the new redesign they
got rid of the chin on the bottom and
the forehead so now you have unified
bezels all the way around and it makes
the controls
for moving in shooting or attacking
closer to the edge which makes it a lot
more convenient now with that said
you're probably wondering about the ipad
air 5 because that just got the m1 chip
now of course it is a lot more powerful
than the a15 in this ipad mini however
it has a huge drawback even though it
has the m1 chip it still only has a 60hz
display just like this ipad mini and
what that means is all of the extra
performance on top of the a15 is
completely wasted when you're doing
things like gaming because this already
hits 60 fps perfect performance with the
a15 so what's the point of the m1 plus
you have the larger ipad air size which
is less convenient to hold in your hand
for gaming so honestly the extra m1 chip
on the ipad air doesn't really matter
and i think going all the way up to the
ipad pro makes a lot more sense because
you get the 120hz pro motion display so
if you want to spend more money than 500
bucks for this ipad mini 6 then just go
straight for the ipad pro and making
this even better this is actually on
sale right now for 460 bucks on amazon
using the link in the pinned comment
below this is just such a crazy deal for
what you get basically the best mobile
gaming device out there now in terms of
the other ways the ipad mini compares to
the ipad air well first of all this
thing comes with a flash which the ipad
air does not and it basically comes with
the same camera system 12 megapixels on
the back and the same 12 megapixel ultra
wide on the front so no real differences
there the main advantage of the ipad air
is actually the usb type c port which is
twice as fast supporting 10 gigabit per
second transfers compared to 5 but for a
lot of people that may not be a big deal
especially if you're using this as an
ipad mainly and one thing i really like
about this redesign is this new folio
case which actually attaches
magnetically which i absolutely love yes
apple packed in magnets into the ipad
mini so you don't have anything wrapping
around the sides super convenient you
just plop on your apple pencil if you
choose to have one and it's just
basically the perfect all-around design
now on top of everything i already
mentioned i do want to reiterate that
this thing is an excellent media
consumption device yes that means
watching youtube videos streaming apple
tv plus hbo max netflix if you're still
subscribed to that maybe who knows but
the display on this is just perfect the
speakers you have on both sides you have
landscape stereo mode so overall
for being an ipad and using it as an
ipad like on your couch anywhere else
taking it with you on the go this is
just so compact the size is perfect for
your hands perfect for your kids hands
i just love this ipad i've got to say
this is my favorite ipad for ipad use so
with that said hopefully you enjoyed
this video and if you did go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one but if you
disagree with me if you think a
different ipad is better let me know in
the comments section below and make sure
to check out one of those two videos
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]